Are companies like people? Companies may not be flesh and blood, but customers view even the largest publicly traded companies very much like the way they view other people. That's according to this episode's guest, social psychologist Susan Fisk. For example, does Netflix have my best interest at heart when it raises its fees or limits streaming? Is the service Amazon Prime competent enough to meet my needs? These are the kinds of questions that run through our minds when we're deciding whether or not to do business with companies. In this episode, we talk with Dr. Fisk about how these thought patterns relate to the way that humans evolved to trust one another. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology.
公司就像人吗？公司可能不是血肉之躯，但即使是最大的上市公司，客户看待它们的方式也与看待其他人非常相似。这是本期嘉宾、社会心理学家苏珊·菲斯克（Susan Fiske）的观点。例如，当Netflix提高费用或限制流媒体播放时，它是否真的为我的最大利益着想？亚马逊Prime服务是否足够胜任以满足我的需求？当我们决定是否与公司进行业务往来时，这些问题就会在我们脑海中闪过。在本期节目中，我们将与菲斯克博士探讨这些思维模式如何与人类进化出的相互信任方式相关联。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），这是《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）。
Susan Fiske is a professor of psychology and public affairs at Princeton University. She has authored hundreds of publications on social behaviors and cognition, and has received numerous scientific awards, including election to the National Academy of Science. She is a co-author of the book, The Human Brand, which combines psychological science, with marketing research to explain how we interact, not just with other people, but also with companies. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Fisk. Thank you. On a fundamental level, your work focuses on how humans interact with one another and how we're
苏珊·菲斯克是普林斯顿大学心理学和公共事务教授。她撰写了数百篇关于社会行为和认知的出版物，并获得了无数科学奖项，包括入选美国国家科学院。她是《人类品牌》（The Human Brand）一书的合著者，该书结合了心理科学与市场研究，解释了我们不仅如何与他人互动，还如何与公司互动。感谢您加入我们，菲斯克博士。谢谢。从根本上讲，您的工作重点是人类如何相互互动以及我们如何
influenced by other people, but your latest book, The Human Brand, looks at how we relate to companies. Can you explain what you and your co-author, Chris Malone, found? What we found is that people surprisingly relate to companies as if they were people. So our psychological research in the past has an ongoing, has found that people make two fundamental time-honored judgments about other people quite quickly and automatically. The first one is friend or foe. Is this person on my side or not? Do they share my interests or not? And can they be trusted? And are they friendly? So that's an instantaneous decision that people make on the basis of a person's face and posture and so on. And the second one is, given that we've infered their intentions, we infer whether they can act on them confidently because their intentions don't matter so much if they're incompetent.
受到他人的影响，但您的最新著作《人类品牌》探讨了我们如何与公司建立联系。您能解释一下您和您的合著者克里斯·马龙（Chris Malone）发现了什么吗？我们发现，令人惊讶的是，人们对待公司就像对待人一样。我们过去的心理学研究一直在进行，研究发现人们会非常迅速且自动地对他人做出两个基本的、经久不衰的判断。第一个是敌友判断。这个人是站在我这一边还是对立面？他们是否与我有共同利益？他们值得信任吗？他们友好吗？所以，这是人们根据一个人的面部表情、姿态等做出的瞬间决定。第二个是，既然我们已经推断出他们的意图，我们就会推断他们是否有能力自信地采取行动，因为如果他们无能，他们的意图就不那么重要了。
So basically, this warmth by competence set of judgments maps out different kinds of human beings in our experiences. And it turns out that people relate to companies in the same way. One of the first things they want to know is whether the company has their interests at heart and the interest of society or are they just self-serving. You know, all companies want to make money, but some of them are more exclusively self-serving than others and don't have the interests of the larger society at stake. And then secondly, how good are they at doing what they set out to do?
因此，基本上，这种“温暖度”与“能力”的判断组合勾勒出了我们经历中不同类型的人。事实证明，人们以同样的方式与公司建立联系。他们想知道的第一件事就是公司是否把他们的利益和社会的利益放在心上，还是仅仅为了自私自利。你知道，所有的公司都想赚钱，但有些公司比其他公司更自私，不顾及更广泛社会的利益。其次，他们完成既定目标的能力如何？
Are they competent or not? So this, you might say, socially evolved strategy that we have for making sense of other people, are they warm and trustworthy or not, and are they competent or not, we use it to relate to companies. And as my co-author, Chris Malone likes to say, you know, back in the old days, people did business with individuals and faces were the first logos. and so people were relating to people they were doing business with in the same warmth by competence framework. But it's spilled over to looking at businesses when you're no longer relating to an individual, but you're relating to a whole company.
他们是否有能力？所以，这种我们用来理解他人的、可以说是社会进化而来的策略——他们是否温暖、值得信赖，以及他们是否有能力——我们用它来与公司建立联系。正如我的合著者克里斯·马龙喜欢说的那样，在过去，人们与个人做生意，面孔是最初的标志。因此，人们在与他们做生意的人打交道时，使用的是同样的“温暖度-能力”框架。但这已经扩展到看待企业，当你不再与个人打交道，而是与整个公司打交道时。
And you mentioned, you know, first impressions, you know, whether it's with someone you encounter on the street or when you walk into a store. Are we making these judgments subconsciously? Are we aware of that we're doing this? I think we're sort of semi-aware. There are automatic components to it. So my colleague Alex Totoroff, for example, shows that in less than a fraction of a second, we decide whether somebody's face is trustworthy or not,
您提到了第一印象，无论是你在街上遇到的人，还是当你走进一家商店时。我们是在潜意识里做出这些判断吗？我们意识到自己在这样做吗？我认为我们处于半知觉状态。其中有自动化的成分。例如，我的同事亚历克斯·托托罗夫（Alex Totoroff）表明，在不到一秒钟的时间内，我们就能决定一个人的脸是否值得信赖，
and then a fraction of a second later, we decide whether the person is competent or not. And we do that on the basis of physical features of their faces. So I think with organizations, they don't have actual literal faces, and so it takes a little bit longer. But, you know, when people say, my cable company hates me or my computer loves me, they're relating to them as if they're trustworthy or not, if they think that Amtrak and the post office are incompetent. You know, those decisions require information to be processed, but, you know, when you're sitting on hold forever and they're playing music you hate and then interspersing it with ads that you hate, I don't know that you're analyzing it, but there's part of you that's saying, these people don't care about my time, they don't respect me, they don't like me. Hmm. People take it very personally, seems like what you're saying.
然后在一秒钟后，我们决定这个人是否有能力。我们是根据他们面部的物理特征来做到这一点的。所以我认为对于组织来说，它们没有实际的字面意义上的面孔，所以需要的时间稍微长一点。但是，当人们说“我的有线电视公司讨厌我”或“我的电脑爱我”时，他们是在把它们当作值得信赖或不值得信赖的对象来对待，如果他们认为美国铁路公司（Amtrak）和邮局是无能的。你知道，这些决定需要处理信息，但是当你一直处于等待状态，他们播放着你讨厌的音乐，中间还穿插着你讨厌的广告时，我不知道你是否在分析它，但你内心的一部分在说，这些人不在乎我的时间，他们不尊重我，他们不喜欢我。嗯。看来您是说，人们对此非常个人化。
They do take it extremely personally. And, you know, it's really surprising when you think about it, the people act as if their consumer products or service corporations have a personal attitude toward them. How do first impressions affect how we compare ourselves with one another? Well, all of our perceptions of other people are relative. So, you know, does this person have my interests at stake, or their own interests only at stake, and are they competing with my interests? But this especially comes out in status judgments. Is this person doing better than I am or worse than I am?
他们确实非常个人化。当你想到这一点时，这真的很令人惊讶，人们表现得好像他们的消费品或服务公司对他们有个人态度一样。第一印象如何影响我们如何相互比较？好吧，我们对他人的所有感知都是相对的。所以，这个人是把我的利益放在心上，还是只把他们自己的利益放在心上，他们是否在与我的利益竞争？但这尤其体现在地位判断上。这个人比我做得好还是比我差？
When people compare up, they attribute competence to people who are higher status, and when they compare down, they attribute incompetence to lower status people. It's almost as if people believe in meritocracy that people get what they deserve, which they might or might not, but people seem to believe that. And so with companies, too, there's an interesting dynamic where luxury brands that are very high
当人们向上比较时，他们会将能力归因于地位较高的人；当他们向下比较时，他们会将无能归因于地位较低的人。这几乎就像人们相信精英管理，即人们得到他们应得的东西，这可能正确也可能不正确，但人们似乎相信这一点。因此，对于公司来说，也存在一种有趣的动态，即非常高端的奢侈品牌
status and you compare up and you say, oh, I want a Jaguar II, people see those luxury brands as being highly competent, just like they see high status people as being highly competent, but not nice. So they see BMWs and Jaguars and Rolex watches and so on as being confident but cold. How can they offset sort of that coldness that you say, some people associate them with. Well, one brand of watch that I know about says, you're not just buying this for yourself,
地位很高，当你向上比较并说“哦，我想要一辆捷豹”时，人们认为这些奢侈品牌非常有能力，就像他们认为高地位的人非常有能力一样，但并不友善。所以他们认为宝马、捷豹、劳力士手表等既有能力又冷漠。他们如何抵消您所说的某些人与他们联系在一起的冷漠感？好吧，我知道的一个手表品牌说，你买它不仅仅是为了你自己，
you're buying it for future generations. I may have a picture of a guy with his young son. So you could bring family into it. It's a little hard with a sports car to do that. Companies like people, they make mistakes all the time. Now, how can they earn back the trust of others? And, you know, what are some differences in similarities and how people and companies regain that trust.
你是为了后代而买的。我可能有一张一个人和他年幼儿子的照片。所以你可以把家庭因素引入其中。跑车要做到这一点有点难。公司就像人一样，他们总是犯错。那么，他们如何赢回他人的信任？而且，你知道，人们和公司在重获信任方面有哪些异同。
Yes, you're right. All companies, you know, have, make mistakes and get into trouble now and again, just as people do. And basically, if they behave honorably about it, the way a person does, so if a person makes a mistake or offends you, if they apologize, you often forgive them if it's a sincere apology and not just sort of pro forma.
是的，你是对的。所有的公司都会不时犯错并陷入困境，就像人一样。基本上，如果他们表现得体面，就像一个人那样，如果一个人犯了错误或冒犯了你，如果你道歉，如果你是真诚的道歉而不是敷衍了事，你通常会原谅他们。
And so when companies say, I'm really sorry, we made a mistake, we take responsibility for this, we'll do our best to make it right as quickly as we can, then people forgive them. And so, for example, with Tylenol, they had a couple of disasters, one where somebody poisoned some of the capsules and one where later on, 10 years later, there was contamination at the plant, they shut down their operations and lost a lot of money making it right. On the other hand, Toyota with some of the issues that it had with its cars and GM with its cars, both companies denied it and ignored the problem and blamed it on the drivers. And, you know, they did not apologize until way late in the game,
所以当公司说，“我真的很抱歉，我们犯了一个错误，我们对此负责，我们会尽我们所能尽快纠正它”，那么人们就会原谅他们。例如，泰诺（Tylenol）经历了几次灾难，一次是有人在胶囊里投毒，另一次是10年后工厂受到污染，他们关闭了业务并损失了大量金钱来纠正错误。另一方面，丰田在汽车出现问题时，通用汽车在汽车出现问题时，两家公司都否认并忽视了问题，并将其归咎于司机。而且，你知道，直到很久以后他们才道歉，
and so they didn't display honorable intentions. So, you know, there are choices in how you handle a disaster like that, and it takes a long time to build trust back, but you have the best chance as a company to build trust. back if you act quickly to show your worthy intentions. How is technology, such as online shopping, change the way people respond to company brands? Well, what's interesting about the online venue is that it doesn't really change the fundamental psychological dynamics. It just makes them faster and makes it crowdsourced.
所以他们没有表现出体面的意图。所以，处理这样的灾难是有选择的，重建信任需要很长时间，但作为一家公司，如果你迅速采取行动展示你值得信赖的意图，你就有最好的机会重建信任。技术，例如在线购物，如何改变人们对公司品牌的反应？好吧，在线场所的有趣之处在于它并没有真正改变基本的心理动态。它只是让它们变得更快，并实现了众包。
So when people have a bad experience with a company, everybody can find out about it very quickly the company can be rated and people tweet about it and blog about it and so on. On the other hand, if the company does something extraordinary and we give the story about Panera doing something extraordinary for somebody's dying grandmother, then everybody can hear about that quickly too and there can be tens of thousands of likes on Facebook. So I think the dynamic doesn't change. It's just faster, which is important because that means that companies have to act on the first instinct to be worthy in the way they're dealing with people because it'll catch up with them
所以当人们在一家公司有糟糕的经历时，每个人都能很快发现，公司可以被评价，人们可以在推特上发帖、写博客等等。另一方面，如果公司做了非凡的事情，我们举出Panera为某人垂死的祖母做非凡之事的例子，那么每个人也能很快听到这个消息，Facebook上可能会有成千上万的点赞。所以我认为动态没有改变。它只是更快了，这很重要，因为这意味着公司必须在处理人际关系时采取第一直觉去表现得值得信赖，因为如果他们不这样做，
if they don't. Well, thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Fist. This has been very interesting. My pleasure. For more information on Dr. Fisk's work and to hear more podcasts, visit our website at speakingof psychology.org. With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
后果会追上他们。好吧，非常感谢您加入我们，菲斯克博士。这非常有趣。我的荣幸。有关菲斯克博士工作的更多信息并收听更多播客，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会《心理学谈话》节目的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。